for eight years
Shin ran shoe hosted a radio program in
China during which she invited women to
call in and talk about themselves words
on the night breeze became known for its
portrayal of what it meant to be a woman
in modern China next listen to their
stories as Shinran discusses her new
book the good women of China it's about
her now arm and thank you very much for
this ancient Institute and thank you
everybody very much for our time for
interesting about Chinese women about my
book and before I come to America I got
phone calls from my ex-colleague he is a
professor of London University then he
said Iran are you ready to go to America
uh 13 years I'm little bit nervous
because it's the first time and the to
America then he said don't worry America
people very intelligent I said are you
sure
he said yes I'm sure because my wife
he's America I said yes was the proofs
about your wife anything very touching
he said actually with my wife now
enjoying the Chinese language a very
much I said oh really I didn't know that
you know I know this lady a long time
then he said oh after she went to your
speech she start enjoying your Chinese I
was so moved I said oh really she could
understand the Chinese suppose she went
to my Chinese feature and he said no no
no he wouldn't we all English his
feature but he feel my English is very
Chinese so I hope today you can join
this kinda English Chinese English and I
come here for my book the book the core
the good women of China
the book is about my program between
1989 to 1997 and my program is about
Charlie's women's alive but before I
start two things I want correction and
from the presenter is I wasn't head of
jung-soo prota gas station I was a part
of head of department not whole station
this is a B I'm not full-time
professional professor I was a part-time
professor and like a guest professor for
many universities in China in London as
well
so I want to be truth in front of you I
said my program in 1989 and that time I
think is the very strange time as you
know since Deng Xiaoping said China
should be opened in 1983 yeah
but six years later people still haven't
got enough knowledge and enough courage
to do something and followed his Wars
because we didn't know was me this
opening and how much we should open and
the worst kind of things we should open
and our feeling is like and like when
you want to discover new food where they
are greedy or you're hungry yeah and
also you fight him to be cured by the
new food at a beginner of the human
being that was my feeling so one way
Studies program we had a no idea how to
do it in that time in China 90% they
were peasants they're farmers so this is
why we decided put my program in the mid
night between 10:00 to 12:00 because
we've thought
peasants went to bad very early so no
one would listen to me to my program and
every day so my program between the 10
to 12 every day from Monday to Friday
it's a weekday when I started I started
by my personal voice before 1989 in Ho
China we say we had a 1 hat as you know
that's Communist Party and the one face
for all of the television and voice for
all of the radio and one pen for all of
the printer papers so when I had my
voice I asked Ottoman people I asked the
listeners I said how are you how did you
do today and are you happy and what I'm
doing and today I come to the whole face
I met some young people in the streets
and it was very good-looking or
something like that
yeah but at beginner I got a lot of the
criticized letters then they said a
Nyonya war is a too soft and too sexual
hooligan but not to America
ok and Abby they said what did you talk
in the radio it's not a revolution and
radical enough so we should be very
strong a communist voice
so even I just said little things every
day just three or five minutes they
could understand and like my colleague
he said this you know I okay I said yes
I'm fine what's wrong he said why in the
program you say you like have a look a
good-looking man I said that's true this
my feeling I think I don't want to look
at an argument at all now he said no you
can say is be careful otherwise there
will be rest so that was I began all
our program so at the beginning my
program is not just for what wasn't for
woman at all but three weeks later just
three weeks later I got more than
hundred letters every day but I was very
silly I didn't take serious so I put all
of the letters in the bigger box man
sometimes I choose will let her with a
beautiful handwriting all the beautiful
stamps or something I open that read it
I didn't take me serious about that
until one day one day I got a letter
with a chicken feather in Chinese
tradition this means an urgent something
very dangerous so one student who I
asked helped me to read the letters then
gave me this letter when I open wait and
this letter come from school boy then he
said I was you know how villager
everybody listened to your program
yeah now I'm writing the letter and not
say this program or how wonderful I just
want to let you know in the village a
lot of the men they both girls from our
side and then now there is old man very
old and life disabled and he just bought
a young girl because he's fighting this
girl run away so he used the heavy
unchain during star was me the metal
chin to lock to this girl and these
girls but it was broken was in the
bleeding
so she said he said in her letter in his
legislation could you harm her so I took
the letter to my director I said can we
do something for this little girl and
director he says you know you should go
to policeman so our telephone please man
I said I need your harp and the priest
man was very cold
he said I'll come down and these kinda
things happen every day we got a lot of
them
from countries that you know you have no
experience you have no idea and now how
much how difficult for us I was very
angry I was very young and also I was
very angry I said do you wanna save her
or not I'm generous I can let my people
know this result that he said I know I
know you're journalists are always you
know can publish what he walked so come
to my office so we had a deal now he
helped me to save this girl disco was
only 12 years old now afterwards no one
said you know you're right
and many colleagues and other people
said I was here just waste time and
money and you know because this little
girl is happening in the countryside
quite a lot because I call lots of the
letters from women so I feel I couldn't
put up with this kinda criticize this is
a girl's life at human life so what's
the value in Chinese people's eyes about
woman I want to know the answer so I
said this question to the air to ask
people what's your view what do you
think about this so lots of people's and
the letter to me told me their story so
I got more and more stories but I was
very silly I didn't understand I thought
because of this a new Chinese woman and
I'm Charlie's woman my mother is Chinese
woman and my friends they are charts
woman so on to you in 1992 I got letter
from a woman I never met her but I
always mentioned her because in my life
she's my great teacher in her letter she
said oh you know everybody cheat here
like star like a woman expert you're
sitting in the studio and officer you
read people's letters announcer people's
a telephone have you thought about
the most woman mother 80% Chinese woman
who are living the country said never be
educated even they don't know how to
write down their name and never heard
about to water electricity and telephone
what about their life so this letter
making me off
so I start researching I started going
out to find out stories but I didn't
know how to do it so first day
I make up dressed up with my microphone
and the record machine why walked in the
street I remember all of the Village
People
run away than they standing far away
pointed to me as a ghost then after 10
minutes that the old man walked to me
very slowly and use his takes the point
my record machine see was that why you
bring this stranger things to our
village so I thought of my god no one
want to speak their life speak out or
her their life to a ghost you know so I
did mystics
so afterwards I learned how to interview
that I didn't know Chinese people's
alive in the countryside
by that time because I grew up in East
patch I know my hometown Shanghai I was
born in Beijing yeah I worked in Nanjing
so this kinda part of China is developed
era and developed where well it's no big
difference from your city and your
country at all but the one I walked into
the just the pass through the middle
china like a shanty hernán and we and
you know we do this kinda part I
couldn't believe what I thought
the people who are living there just
like 500 years ago I knew that from
history book because our light books
very much so every time I went there I
always wear the poor and old
even dirty clothes and without any
equipment without a pen without a paper
at home as well I work in to the village
I asked them what are you doing here
the woman looked at me always very
stretcher they asked me first question
are you a woman I say yes I'm a woman
then she said oh I'm cooking for my man
I'm doing I'm making shoes for children
so I said could you teach me they said a
how old are you I said more than 35 they
said even you have 35 you don't know how
to do it up for our woman so do you
really teach him they taught me lots of
they told me lots of a story about their
life so this is why today I can making
shoes I can making clothes I can making
lots of the countryside food because I
learned from them and the during this
kind of learning I heard a lot of lots
of stories not someone I couldn't
believe that during my program about 80
years I interview Chinese woman like
this face to face at more than 200 some
story is I went to their family to get
it some story come to me by someone who
I didn't know that in my burka is total
15 chapters except my childhood her my
mother and is about another 12 women
stories
and before why decide which story I
should put in this book I feel the very
difficult I began I had a 30 stories
because each story in my life so
important and means quite a lot so
afterwards I had to take off for 15 and
keep 15 in the book in these 15 stories
you can see the Chinese little girl or
Chinese grandmother and you can see
Chinese woman who are living the very
rich era and that the people who are
living the very poor and today because
time is very short and always I won't
leave some time for you for your
questions so I will tell you some
stories
the first story are always very moved
about a little girl who kept a fly as
her pet I got the story very early and
why start program and one day I got a
book straw shoes for shoes books and in
the books full of the piece of the
papers I didn't know was that
so after program I put all of the paper
in order then I found that his theory of
the little girl this girl was abused by
her father then she wouldn't to her
mother asked her for her now her mother
said oh don't say anything we'll have to
keep quiet because Chinese culture is
kind of hiding culture I think if you
have some Chinese friend if you come
from Chinese family you know that we
hardly to have any conversation about
past so this girl couldn't get any herb
so she tried very hard to hurt her own
body
she put cold water in
her clothes in her body then she's done
she stood outside in winter she tried in
any way to want to be sent to the
hospital for awarding her father's
attacked so one day she was in a
hospital the little fly touch her skin
she feel so beautiful
now afterwards she tried to keep her fly
as her pot pad but as you know fly how
life is like a very disgusting
so everybody want to clean or try cute
fly so she couldn't keep this her fly so
after her fly died she was told she's
better she should go home
this girl was very fighter she didn't
want to go home so she put that I'd fly
to the cut of her arms then she got
horrible blood problem then she died so
after this story I went to the street
next day I went to the public qatal it I
just want to feel her failing so one
that fly touched my skin I cried cried
in the street even so many people knew
me I didn't care because can you imagine
the torture by the fly legs that's a
tiny touching but this girl was so
hungry from this kind of human dodging
and human-loving so after this story I
told my mother as a commune stand my
mother said if I say yes because I have
a woman I want to be touched if I say no
because I'm Chinese woman because our
culture were not used to hock to each
other attached to each other even mother
and the daughter she's right
so when she come to London visit me two
years ago I said could you hug me I love
it
my mother's face become rad she said no
no I'm Chinese I'm not used to so why
told the story in Australia during the
Morgan Writers Festival the woman in
Australia in the Melbourne they took a
lump you forgiving me hard
one by one the taxi driver waited for me
said I Drive to about 20 years I never
saw like this that people just won't
give you heart take a long view that
that is this kind that you know Chinese
woman's failing another story in this
book is about a group of mother
all of them lost their children in
earthquake in 1976 I think in this city
you had this kind of experience happened
twice very seriously when snotty know
six ways 1989 is right so in 1976 China
we had a horrible earthquake happened in
puncture just nearby Beijing we lost
about 300,000 people's life and the
whole city almost disappeared under
because of very serious and resort
people in the army they couldn't reach
the error at all because of road anyway
it's broken down so I heard about story
about group mother all of them they lost
their children then they used their
pension phone helped the other children
who lost their parents so I interview
one mother when I heard a her story I
just couldn't believe that she was there
watching her daughter was dying in 14
days
because the people couldn't save her she
was not between two buildings the army
reach there and lot of people helped her
but they couldn't get her out so this is
another one days passed
she put her daughter's big huge photos
just eyes on the wall then he put two
wars in her daughter's eyes see for
future she's so great then she helped
the other children I'm mother I have a
son his pen pal he called papa
he's 14 years old if something happened
to him I don't think I have enough
courage to look after other children or
to touch other children's face or hands
but she is doing everyday so when I
interview them I just filled oh my god
this is mother Charlie's mother under
another story actually is quite Lord
another story in my last chapter it's
called a woman who are living the shot
in Hill why I want to tell you the story
because this is the last chapter the
14th chapter about fashion a woman who
is very rich she has 80 cars one car for
Monday one car for Tuesday you know
she's very rich she's living in the
Shanghai but she told me she wasn't
happy
during my program about 80 years 99% to
complete their life yeah and then
someone said I'll see I'm very shy
shopping every day but every morning I
couldn't find clothes to wear
yeah but someone said to me always here
I'm not happy because I couldn't get a
money go to school to study as other
people
so unhappy his is so different so I
really want to know who is happy
so why went to the shouting Hill I got
the answer the woman who are living
there they told me they are happy but
what about their living condition
they never had any electricity and cheap
water even drinking water the woman who
living there had no right to have same
meal as men so they every day they only
have one ball of the soup very clean a
soup every day just went under one
family eight daughters they share one
clothes one thought her word clothes
going out with a mother to do some
housework another seven sitting the
batter covered a bedsheet and also some
things very strange when I saw them when
they grew up
the woman is working sterile not like us
yeah like that they're working like this
I couldn't understand why so I asked
them what's the reason and they said you
should ask a grandmother there is a
grandmother in the village she was 45
she's oldest person in a village life
there is so short then she said oh yeah
that gee because we are short of the
water and the material things so we
haven't got woman care things so for the
period they used the turn leaves very
hard leaves for their blood during the
period and every woman in their whole
life
their whole property just a turn piece
of the leaves because the leaves are so
hard so broken their legs
they couldn't working as normal but they
told me they're happy I said why and
they said because it will have men will
have children will have family that's
enough so when I left this village
shouting Hill my friends my colleagues
asked me cheer on did you turn them your
life I said oh no I couldn't
I thought that his murder because they
are happy if I told them what I have but
they couldn't get it yeah they were
become unhappy so in my book is 15
chapters like that but I like the title
very much is called the good woman of
China when many people could understand
the whys you know under the traditional
standard no one in the book is good yeah
I said that this is a very sad I
certainly the question to the air in
1995 to the Chinese man I said okay
today I opened the hot full hot line
okay
could you answer my question how many
woman in your life have you mad and it
was your standard of good woman so I
send all the questions I waited for them
20 minutes no one called me back but
three weeks later I call thousands
letters then most the latter said they
never met good woman in their life more
than 90% possibly 99% only few men said
they had a good woman in their life so
they gave me the standard of the good
woman I couldn't believe that but I
thought possibly because Charlie's
courage her Oh
something wrong in that time so I met
another man in Australia who just
finished PhD and have been there about
15 years and he married a woman who I
hated about Americans education system
in a university and he told me exactly
same things he said good woman a is
never open her mind her serve to other
people to the society to other men
that's ok no boyfriend at all so be she
should gave the son to the family for
family tree see the woman never lose
temper always a warm and soft to the man
does next ways this woman never does
housework wrong never meets the color
when she washed the clothes would never
burn the food when she cooked yeah the
last Sunday's should be very good in the
bad and they're very good figures for
going out this is a five point of good
woman this is why so many Chinese woman
there's so unhappy because everybody
come to this world we want to be good
girl good daughter good wife good mother
good grandmother yeah if we spend the
whole life forgiving for loving but
afterwards no one's they were good it's
a very sad so someone asked me yeah this
is because communist party or revolution
culture revolution I answered I said I
don't think Communist Party and the
Cultural Revolution has this kinda
powerful can change a woman's life
because I
we come from the past about 7,000 years
in a fluster 5,000 years in China before
nineteen nine nineteen yeah Matty we
never had freedom of religion never had
a sex education never had freedom press
and never had independent the legal
system so this time the full time the
basic human need we didn't have so
Chinese women never be taught they had a
right to speak out they had their own
Wars boys and worse to say something so
when I had this book I thought I should
be little bit relaxed on my life Lee to
be the light but unfortunately I
couldn't because in the day time asked
you you know I can't come true myself I
can steer smiling to everybody but in
the night I don't know why the story in
the books and out of the books still
come to me again again again so when I
left China in 1997 and many Chinese
woman sent a letter to me say how Syrian
we hate you we love you also we hate you
you know we want to you so much than you
want Livie but I promised them I said I
will work much harder than before I will
bring your story to the world now we'll
take people's answer what is good woman
back to China and we needed to listen
other people's voice not just our
tradition voice so I did I tried and I
hope there will be happy and also I hope
you can tell me what's your standard of
the good woman
I have my email address and I have a
copy here which was signed by many
people many Chinese and America already
because the book is going to be
published in 2023 languages over 55
countries so I will go to many countries
one by were about twenty two so each
country I have a copy so I beg you
everybody who are here today to sign
some sentence for my boy for Chinese
woman and I want two people no I want
Chinese women can feel we're not just
alone in the corner we have so many
friends all of the world and also so
many people they listen our stories and
why come to this count
come to England I read lots of the books
about Chinese women's life but I found
most the book were written by the people
who left the China so the story in my
book except myself most of them are
hundred percent of them that had no
chance left China so this is why I want
my book can open tiny hole in the bigger
war which is sarong China about three
thousand years and you can see the
Chinese woman's altering woman's life by
your own eyes and you can understand
their life by your own experience so
this is why I write the book and also I
have a lot of the stories now they are
waiting for your questions if you want
just you can answer your questions thank
you for thank you for this
thank you
1 I don't think this is just a Chinese
problem if the fact of not being hugged
is very stoic Nordic personality - my
question for you is at this current
state since there was the policy of only
one child and people wanted boys there
is a disproportionate number of boys of
marriageable age - women do you think
this will bring them some kind of
respect or place in their society
because there's a small enough number
that they're very important for the next
generation to come or do you think that
this will bring you more grief to them
because there are not enough young women
the current population of young Chinese
men very interesting question I think
this question is quite lost people want
to know and there is an extra
information in your hands and I said to
people and my life or my experience
about China life drop of the water you
know China like a big ocean I don't
think I can explain how things about
China but I do think I can explain a cup
of green tea about China I like to
answer your question about ASA in fact I
went to lots of the countryside and
mountain era in that in those plays the
women is much more than men because many
family they did believe they do believe
if you got more children
you got more property in a more future
for Maliki because things 200 300 BC to
500 AD in China we set up a very strong
the tax policy by the entrance if you
have the more boy they gave you more
land so after that by the generations
the people do believe boys a can
continue family treated in Chinese
tradition this is the number one
important and the second way is if you
have more children
you get a more property more lands
because so far China still eighty
seventy eight percent they are farmers
in the patterns but in a big city in
eastern China like Shanghai Beijing
Guangzhou this time place you are right
the boy the man woman sir now is like a
fourteen men when woman about twenty
ages in in their countries it's very
serious
so I I remember I telephone my friend
who works for government as this single
child policy and governor then she said
to me she says you know we have to
control the population with a rather
lighting boys or men couldn't find a
wife than lighting woman a children next
generations couldn't gather clothes or
food this is that they are bill I just
pass through the information to you I
think of a woman is quite difficult
because they have to give up lots of the
baby goes yeah
the humans rights issue is probably one
that you didn't ask a lot about in
regards to China nunnery men and women
that I mean just the general population
do you think the humans rights issues
has is it getting better and is it
getting better
how and you know just generally I think
her question is this kind of the human
right of human being China is getting
better I do believe is getting better
and this happen already I'm freelance
producer for television and radio for
both side a UK and China as well and I
went back China quite often in this
March who I went back China last time
and first time I saw to come the
happiness and relax from people's eyes
in the street yeah and like young people
even they are in their 30 30 s they hug
to each other and the kiss to each other
in the street without any warning at all
but not above the middle age it's very
difficult let them work out the black
shadow of the tradition and I do think
now is much better my feeling is the
picture was in front of me why start a
program in 1989 like group Chinese
people they are standing on the top of
the mountain they want to jump they want
to cure themselves now they're still
standing there the position hasn't
changed but their face become more
relaxed and not faced bath they are
faced to the bigger landscape they start
enjoying talking about their life this
is my theory and you can look at my
hands
yeah and many people ask me why I
painting this right actually two reasons
one reason is why I start my question to
Chinese woman I found its word
difficult to let them open their mind in
the mouse to you so I tried to do some
stupid things in my face or on my hands
then they were always asking me say why
you gotta love Green Point here when
they star their question they
interesting enjoying the conversation so
I can ask their question this is a one
point reason so I always did some
different things
another reason in my heart in my my I
really feel Chinese women's position was
here now they improved here yeah I hope
they can improve very quickly to here
and all of the ten fingers but I think
that they moved thank you
is that a question how do you do it was
a lovely talk thank you very much
I lived in Hong Kong in the late 80s and
the 90s and although I didn't attend
there was a International Women's
Conference in Beijing I think in about
1990 and I wondered if you had attended
it or knew anyone who did the people who
came back and came through Hong Kong
were extremely excited about it and they
said that a lot of things had been put
in place or a lot of organizations had
formed to help women in China and I just
wondered if you knew anything whether
that was there was any follow-through
with that thank you I think I know
something because I know I have to say I
don't know and I just like I had a three
interviews in America yeah the first
person called a Susan page she went to
China three times one times with Jimmy
Carter and other times with government
and this time with the maybe George Bush
I don't know and she went there well I
asked her do you know China she said oh
I'm sorry I don't know and another man
she caught he I'm sorry I couldn't
remember his name he's dark that dick
dick is tall
it's a in the Washington DC now he had
been China eight times why I asked him
do you know China he said I don't think
of my face can let me know China where
well even I got there eight times but I
met her expert about Chinese about China
he's in New York when he before he
interviewed me everybody said he's grid
expert about China I said when I walked
in his studio he said hallo
in Cantonese to me as I'm sorry I can't
speak Cantonese but I can speak Mandarin
I I said Oh everybody say you're expert
or China can I know how can you know
China so well yeah he said uh oh you
know I have been lived in China huh more
than 10-15 years so I asked him again I
said have you had some Chinese friends
he said yes I have two Taiwanese seven
mainland Chinese and the twenty
Cantonese I said what they are doing
they said all of them working in China
huh so I said have you been China
he said not yet so it's very good
question I think the question my answer
is in China we have the building for
women we have office for women we have
names for women we have people who are
working for women but the problem is
because in last hundred years China
hadn't got enough time to be still in
the peaceful time to have enough
education and information and modern
technology so even we have the office we
have the name all of the office building
organization but we haven't gotten mine
how to do it
I think this is a problem sorry
in those parts of China where education
is most advanced can you can you
describe for us the status of such a sex
education sex education yeah
unfortunately before the February of
this year in China we never had sex real
sex education why I went back China in
the March and no one heard of a
publisher he told me was very exciting
about this he said they were going to
publish first the sex education textbook
in China just in March this first time
yeah this is why I was very you know in
the book I told you a story while was
turned why was 22 years old
you know I was in army and my command
because I got big prize my commander
come to me want to handle my hand I said
that is in the night in a moonlight by
the fire I said no I don't want you two
days everybody said oh come on he's a
big commander and the high rank of why
you refuse him I said I don't want to
get a baby I was a 22 because I read the
book called a Torian from who if you are
Chinese you know the book in the book of
they said the man the boys and a girl
they handled each other in the moonlight
a second second the Sun Times said next
spring they have the big boy so I
thought why was 22 I thought if we
handle my hand in the moonlight I will
get a pregnant yeah so yes please I was
wondering if your book has been
translated into Chinese and has there
been in the official reaction from the
government
Joyner and in fact this book is
translated from Chinese to English so I
writer in Chinese I can't write in
English you know I told my translator I
said if I understand your English that
is bad if I can't stand that is good so
actually this book is going to be
published in China by Shanghai during
the publishing halls in Chinese we say
Chaka sanlian and they I never my thumb
just by a telephone if they knew me they
heard about my name and my program and
they told me one morning in London times
three o'clock early morning and the head
of the publishing house he called me
that he said Oh Sarah how many tears and
I said oh I'm sorry I mean dream he said
and he said I must tell you the story in
your book is not very fresh and anew and
the most Chinese people knew the story I
said yes I know I was still sleepy then
he said but I have to say you keep them
voice very well I said thank you for
your understanding
now he said here can we send the book to
Chinese universities I just I couldn't
say anything I think that's a wonderful
idea so I asked him I said why he said
actually your book is the most
difficulties for Chinese people because
older generation we don't want to speak
out young generation we don't know that
just like this book so many Charlie
overseas Chinese student when they read
the book they asked me see and is true
in your book I said it don't ask me ask
your parents hundred percent replied to
me say my parents said yes that's true
but I asked them why your parents never
told you the story yeah but afterwards I
understand like Germany and Japan after
Second World War
their last generation never told a new
generation was happened in this new
country and also I feel is on
fear you you couldn't find another book
to talk about this everybody say in that
Second World War Great America greater
UK yeah and they said oh after 1956 new
generation in Germany and the Japan
rebuilt they rebuild a new country but
what happened after Second World War
Between the Second World War and the
true 1956 they are woman carried a whole
country when they lost the man they
brought up their children so I think it
is a little bit unfair but in China the
same but I'm so glad this book is going
to be publishing China and also will
send lots of the universities and this
is the reason I didn't ask them for high
price yeah thank you
you say that you were broadcast
originally late at night so that the
peasants couldn't hear your broadcast
and I'm wondering why you believe you
were ever let on the air at all sorry
why do you think you were ever allowed
to air your program at all
y-yes what you said that you were
broadcast late at night so that the
peasants could not hear you yeah the
restrictions but why do you think they
even allowed the program to begin with I
know I think my and my my story is
because I was nervous you know because I
wasn't sure what kind of things that I
should talk and I wasn't sure about my
knowledge can manage it is kind the
program so I put this a program in a
meteorite and the pattern I thought the
persons and 90 percent people went to
bed very early it's a few people
listened to my program not they don't
allow they did our love and they loved
it
yeah thank you
it's done okay I wanted to ask how you
made the decision or how it came to be
that you ended your program when you did
in 97 and what the process was for you
to what this is how you made a decision
to go to London and also if you plan to
it what are your thoughts on moving back
to China and why I moved to London then
program or why the program ended when it
did in 97 yeah okay um I think after 80
years I just feel it's too much for
myself that time I took 8 sleeping pill
every night otherwise I couldn't sleep
at all if we will read the book I do
believe some of you reader some chapters
already that's of quite heavy just you
know very woman feeling hot parched and
Horsell you'll feel they're very
difficult that is part of our own life
our own that nature so afterwards I
couldn't carry so much the second reason
is after 80 years I I talk every day I
thought I need energy of the knowledge I
need a power of the knowledge to improve
myself otherwise just play the game with
my audience and the third way so my boy
was in the school so I won't gave him to
pester education so I moved to England
thank you I said I'm sorry
do you think that the reason that women
were so little valued in the Chinese
culture was because of the history and
tradition of Confucianism and Daoism
okay this your question and actually I
think no matter your belief religion or
not when we read the history of the
world of most countries a culture
language and customs come from religion
that religion is kinda rules of your
culture your language your customs but
in China unfortunately we hadn't got
this kinda religion at all as you
mentioned the confuse the recorder
confusion and the tall and the Buddha
they happened the much later than
Chinese culture and tradition and
language because all of the happened in
the 1,300 about a confusion a BC yeah
and Buddha moved to come to China about
80 0 and thought it happened that 1200
something like even later maybe 300 BC
so it's much later than our tradition
culture and beliefs so this is what I
feel Chinese very difficult for Chinese
people to work out of this kind of heavy
tradition because we never had a God
Chinese people from ancient time we
treat our Emperor's and rulers as God
but it can you imagine the God always
changed yeah and a new God always this
point the old of God so this is why
Chinese people in your eyes or soul
materials they frightened to lose
something because they are not sure what
happened the next day
so we'll have the sentence II don't
borrow the light sunlight from turbo
tomorrow yeah this is why we fight him
so Chinese character is kind and hard we
say no secret a culture not safe culture
and a very hiding culture and a very
negative culture as well why I said is
if you learn Chinese yeah
first the words you're learning is
Noreen Ali paka paka pushing with you
yeah if you have beautiful daughter yeah
if you say Oh your daughter is so
beautiful then Chinese family must say
oh no no no no they are not beautiful so
people grew up in this kind of hiding a
negative culture so I think this is a
tradition sorry I think she's waiting in
a long time okay how did men feel about
your program did they criticize your
program or were they encouraging you um
very interesting question and actually
in the later of my program because I
thought a conversation between the
Chinese family generations the men a
woman's are so little and a commissary
is so important for woman's nature woman
need a talk you know even when you the
neck yeah but in China we couldn't get
their chance this is why suicide number
in China is a high number
so I said Harper for long time record
machine I said to my audience I said you
can call me in between 8 o'clock to 12
don't tell me your name don't hire me
where you are you just let your story
out now you feel the better yeah but
during this lots of the women they said
oh now I feel better I can go on my life
that's true saved a lot of the people's
life but also some man calling say
Sharon listen if you go and support a
woman like that I will cure you at a
gate of yours
the issue as well and also something is
quite interesting in nineteen and office
95 I said another question to their to
the man I said could you tell me your
mother's name or your wife's name then
say I love you very simple for hotline
whole night no one called me at home
then I asked my colleague he's a very
idea created person and he's a famous DJ
I said why he said it's Iran don't be
silly Chinese man loves their woman in
heart not a mouse not enhance I said
well human we needed to be touched that
we needed to be told so we come from
very different philosophy Shinran Shu
was born in Beijing in 1958 the good
women of China hidden voices is her
first book and it's published by
Pantheon books a division of Random
House visit Random House dot-com /
Pantheon for more info